welcome to this rapid game Terry Malloy
yeah 25 10 is the time control and some
yeah it gets more and more established
now
I mean shake it's not in that software
yet
wow you get that the Albion count again
okay what about this person now you
don't see how many big games he has
played in the - a software they really
have to update that so I have no idea if
that is an establish trading or whatever
that is okay if I do the best 25 no it's
also not really working
Oh amazing so let's go before
yeah that's um one of the ways to play
against the the elements and it's it's
the current current a main main line
against it if it has something like a
main line it's a very that's not a very
popular opening on a somewhat higher
level so hardly a main line available
but white is mostly doing is giving that
pawn back for a good position with
Bishop on d4 is very strong it's not
easy for black to get some development
going if I go Bishop d3 no maybe yes got
Queen g5 double attacking g2 and b5
maybe Knight f5 forever is a move that
okay it's not sure how problematic it is
it is a problem after Knight c3 let's
say then I don't really have a decent
move maybe develop that no at first that
shouldn't be a bad idea
now 9f5 I can drop it back to c3 or b2
and then later win the temper with
Bishop d3 okay
so interesting move I don't really like
to play a four here that much but okay
ed weakens before he might have liked
Knight moves and something should be
formed
okay so bishops III that's clear now
yeah Bishop b2 at some in other cases
would have been an alternative but then
Bishop before has a pretty awkward pin
so I probably have to go to c3 anyway
and the night letter v I am not sure
about it's not a particularly stable
piece thing is that this pawn structure
e for b5 against b7 c7 I mean by design
is good for white because I'm limiting
his pawn there on the C file it quite
often will turn out to be a weakness I
cannot really tell you if this rating is
from many games the - of software is not
working properly with the 25 pool yet so
no but okay we see that despite that
fishy opening he played well afterwards
now the Albin's is not a good opening it
but it's not something that is like like
totally totally destroyed by white
that's not possible you will get a good
position but you won't win outright
that a three-line that I played Ellis
Ellis is the current um yeah mainline um
it's not the sharpest continuation there
are a couple of other lines that are a
little bit more yeah more after
refutation but I don't know them yeah I
wonder what's what is he going to do
something like Bishop before I might
just take like win b2 and win that
pawned okay I can kick and keep that
with Quinn he's seven I it's probably
not a good idea anyway after almost any
moves I'm probably it's an interesting
question if I should play Bishop to d3
or a move like Bishop c4
yeah surprisingly low thought from him
he's not disconnected right you know
it's got a fantastically fantastically
good connection so he just takes a
longer thing here
yes something like Bishop e7 is a
normal-looking move yeah I wonder if he
is varied in some way about the movie
for like a 494 queen bee - but the
knight can be supported by rook th
things like that so if I was probably
rubbish that's a bit worrisome that long
think even though I didn't get a
disconnection information when I paint
him it's kind of weird
I think well I guess we should be seven
if he goes roopd aid or something I can
take a five I mean I really will take
that pawn or maybe is he worried about
night C for that that's that's an
interesting question actually something
that I should have thought of before
Rihanna Knight c4 and it took me a long
while right as a problem let's say he
goes Bishop e7 I play nine C for
attacking a five he absolutely cannot go
be sixty to ninety five so he really led
this one yeah he gives me that pawn in
simple English okay I don't really think
I can decline that
yeah it was I didn't spend much time on
it but I had thought about it before me
beforehand
I can't just back he gained a little bit
of time but it still has not changed the
fact that the possible Knights e4 to e5
will basically wipe him out
getting the Knight to c6 I just wonder
is that right or I wonder if that is the
right way to do it or just something
like Bishop b2 and develop its it's not
apparent what what is compensation is
for the pawn yeah come on let's just
complete development not move pieces
again and again like 94 so is there
something wrong with castling
yeah I really don't think he's got
anywhere near sufficient compensation i
still have 90 45 to c6 but i think it
was better to get my King out of there
first
yeah can you help to seek at some kind
of counter plane moving moving pieces
towards my king but it's not so easy
yeah like then let's say Bishop d6 or
something I have Nazi form directly
going after that Bishop
I'm take that night to h4 I can't just
go g3 if everything else fails
yeah I don't know yeah Katie tries that
one tries that one 93 is also move that
that comes to mind you might have Bishop
F babish about five I got Queen B -
that's good
oh wait neither three net let's just I
mean I have time I'm playing a bit too
quickly here really I can take a little
bit of time them night to D forever
that's very tempting if it takes it
Bishop takes I have Bishop c6 as a
possible idea
okay yeah I think I think I'll do that
trading it is one idea but the other
thing is that 94 yeah that would be nice
to get in 94 possibly to set more than
once to c6 now let's undo that pre move
our screws of the board view I can take
it Bishop c4 but group d1 really not
leading anywhere
995 is he still in the game it's really
still in the mix shouldn't forget about
that if he I don't know I'm not quite
sure what his movies but 95 shouldn't be
forgotten it's pretty strong in some
cases still with the night coming to c6
okay that move I did not think of at all
okay maybe I take it Bishop h3 King h1
that doesn't and doesn't strike me as
particularly great for black but I
wonder about 95 that that let's let's
start like that
and 95 what is he doing after that if he
get was like 26 or so I take g2 and I'm
just a piece up for nothing and if he
goes to c8 I can go knight c6 I mean I
can also just take g2 it's it's the it's
almost the same thing but knight c6
still looks pretty good
still I wonder if I
I wonder if I fatigue on g2 is checking
me on age three teenage one okay I
assured g-force nonsense if I go to c6
now let's think about it for a moment
look at these seven I can actually came
this happy looks crazy
he will go rupee head probably I wonder
if it is a good thing to have that
knight on c6 or not it sometimes can be
can be misplaced to be perfectly honest
probably right let's do it
one thing is that if he moves his rook
somewhere I can take it seven no he
doesn't really so why can a lot take on
d8 that is interesting I don't get it
what is she doing it like Bishop t54
some crazy move for Queen age three it
would be that would be out of this world
or something like that would actually
work
I can still take take them
on g2
Queen evo is also pretty decent move
just trying to take that piece it cannot
do anywhere can only play Bishop h3 and
then still the bishop or the knight is
trapped that is a candidate yeah queenie
for for like conveniently taking that
piece queenie for bishop age three i can
just grab the ain't I guess queenie for
Bishop d5 as a possible
but then I play quindi for mating 1 g7
f6 and if our faults was Czech
so Queen B for Bishop b5 Queen D for
this win I think so
what is left okay but so there's 90 hmm
but I couldn't really efficiently
high-flux totally crazy after that for
Queen h3 you aren't exactly the kind of
nonsense that sometimes lose against the
King I think we need for is a simple way
to do it his Bishop is trapped and I
still have retained that option to take
the exchange on the aide
let's say he goes on Bishop h3 now to
protect that night I can take on the 898
rook the 8th Bishop f3 and the Knight
has nowhere to go so is that a moment
now to to take or is there something
different let's just try to calculate
that properly Bishop d3 is also
mmm make sure if it wins though even
though we Adams f5 is probably probably
possible so 98 that's the first move
really to check 98 I cannot really it
mooses night some way it doesn't really
have a check or anything I think I can
take it let's let's take that exchange
first I don't see anything right now huh
I think rook takes is the simple reply
and then I was planning to play Bishop
f3 just intending to take the knight it
cannot go to age for me it can but uh
but I take that and at the end like
Bishop f3 9h for Queen takes H for
Bishop everyone look everyone I'm I'm a
piece up okay so he went with this
capture this way he retained the
possibility to cover
I mean h4 is now it's now covered that's
what I'm trying to say so with a go
Bishop g4 that's maybe Queen to h4
that's something that could easily lead
to trouble
what about Bishop g4 Bishop g4 Queen h4
Bishop f3
Shuji for Queen h4 Bishop f3 should edge
to teenage - it's not leading anywhere
webshop g4 check still possible maybe
huh okay
I also thought about Queen to f3 just
taking that bishop but then Queen h4 and
if you chose
okay I can also go Queen d4 and I Queen
D for this Queen d5
hmm that's not so not that easy actually
night to hy it's it's still kind of kind
of messy a little bit so let's this
let's think about it going to defy
everything it's amazing I Bishop g4
Queen h4 just kind of okay probably
Bishop f3 Bishop takes age to King edge
to Bishop g4 check and then King g1
that's the end node actually
so think about it again Bishop g4 and
the otherwise it would basically a
Bishop g4 on okay Brooke cook something
else cream defaulted we win it's still a
tricky position amazingly enough
before quitting rubbish were three
there's really no a Bishop g4 maybe
Bishop g4 and I'm gonna take what the
Queen down well it's kind of complicated
Bishop g4 no it's not
so I'm calculating complete nonsense yep
Bishop g4 Queen h4 Bishop Bishop g4 the
kind of irritating
it's playable it's really playable Wow
it's it's not that easy
what it's really not that easy
okay so whatever playing king h1 for
Luke g1 maybe it's a typical way
sometimes to screw it up yeah you
calculate some some deeper lines don't
get anywhere and then you play the first
move that comes into your mind and
that's total rubbish okay but I don't I
don't see a problem with it at the
moment
main idea what you won of course even if
I really get rook g1n then he wouldn't
be able to move his Knight due to
destruction on g7 maybe Bishop d3 would
have been good huh maybe that one was
the solution I was silly I should've
thought about that [ __ ] up d3 of course
that would have been interesting if he
if he in that case like g6 I have Queen
D for mating oh I guess they were I have
six something and f6 would stop his
Queen from this block him from that
Queen to h4 can a medium so maybe Bishop
d3 would have been good
yeah either then that was very sloppy
looking and looking at candidate moves
in a very sloppy way problem yeah I'm
guilty guilty as charged not doing
candidate moves properly came so Luke g1
that was the was the point he is
threatening Bishop g2 anyway so I
probably have to do it nothing happening
yep tonight comes back
okay what is smiles now I wonder have
Queen d4 still an idea 95 should fail
due to F 4 and F 6 is not a very
attractive move no it's not a very
attractive move but it also not helps
Bishop c4 check King edge aid rook takes
g6 it takes at Queen h4 checkmate ha
I've seen a tactic but anyway Queen
deform this says something what he can
do
yes the check on a8 that's something not
to be ignored that's actually quite
important
f3s Bishop e5 after them and I'm not a
winning immediately it's not bad but
it's not ideal
okay so very tempting to do I have to
admit okay um the Queen before f6 Bishop
c4 check that really wins but he has
that chicken they ate ha
that's not good so I said look Quinn
nice idea so let's think about it what
am I actually playing after having
thought about this nice but probably
irrelevant possibility for quite a while
so I still like it
come on let's play for a little trickier
I know it shouldn't do that but so I
feel tempted they would probably give
that check but it's not a problem in f3
I'm okay but should be five Queen c4 or
something I'm okay then now it's got to
be six I'm not a good idea
playing for tricks it's not a good idea
not a good idea
now after that check yeah three Bishop
e5 I don't have a good square for the
Queen on top of everything okay Mike
Wynn d2 uh so I mean it's not like great
truth it doesn't change the fact that
I'm even exchanged up so nothing bad
happened but yeah he's probably seeing
it that f6 loses very swiftly well maybe
it no I just lost I was 15 I was just
thinking f6 Bishop c4 check King h8 rook
takes G 6 and then the check on a 8 but
I have Bishop d5 that ends the whole
affair very quickly check yep so 3 see
any other alternative
yeah Queen 22 let's let's do that group
d8 Queen B 2 and then he has to trade
they are playing for that little trick
probably was a silly idea yeah humans
are weak cannot resist temptation
temptation for cheap Trick's a case
going back just like that ah yeah it's
what is there a particular idea of 95
maybe
24:05 is just a repetition that that's
useless they don't really see any kind
of threat from him so I'm going to do
this trying to use my look on anyone I
expect them to take and then I can check
with the rook that makes my rook active
this far more active than it was on a
one hint behind that porn
yeah Queen b7 I guess
seems quite quite likely I don't know is
he planning no if he goes to d8 I have B
six cakes Ruti five wins the bishop it's
a little tactic probably not bad I
expect Queen B seven that also would
prevent any b6 ideas just by Queen takes
b6
and I still have to be cautious it can
easily happen that that um that you
overlook some detail here
I wonder if I go quickly different again
Bishop e5 it's their alternative move
doesn't look like it
flash your move would be like be six
cheeks no it's not looking you can take
with the Queen if everything else fails
you can take with the Queen so how to
how to continue here we can also think
about what blacks ideas are he cannot do
that much
I wonder if Bishop Bishop d4 Farouk a7
is a move it's probably not bad
but also not helping much to be to be
honest doesn't help much
I like Ruka for preventing I mean it
doesn't really prevent night h4 wasn't
threatened anyway that's what I'm trying
to say but it is useful on the
fourth-ranked I believe
yeah I think Black has a little bit more
play than certainly was necessary
King h1 was probably not the best move
yeah and my playing on on a trick that
probably probably not very advisable I
mean I don't really see anything
dramatic happening to me but still it
felt like there should have been better
solutions
I wonder if rook h4 is somewhat of a
threat here if he takes a trip g7 will
will definitely win but rook edge for
the bishop it retreats yeah maybe like
rook edge for Bishop back rook h5 this
kind of thing that just makes some sense
activate the rook on to h5 at yeah maybe
hey okay it's his move and it's pretty
important that his Plex move he will
very likely move the rook somewhere and
introduce ideas like nectar rook t-84
possible discoveries even though the
room hang so okay he he retreated that
Bishop voluntarily so what is the point
of it yeah I wonder do I play rook h4 is
that just moved to just a show of moves
that doesn't really lead anywhere that's
often a problem you see a flashy looking
move and then you feel challenged but
it's not that great actually yeah I
don't know but it looks good here right
I don't see an argument against it at
the moment the idea is really rook h5
where it would have a good position on
the fifth-ranked secures my my pawn LH 2
and both rooks
are doing something the weird thing is
that rook h4 in itself doesn't carry a
threat and it puts it on a protected
square but he cannot take out rook g7
[ __ ] King h8 rook takes f7 check King g8
rook g7 check King h8 rook takes c7
check and I'm winning the Queen at the
end
I don't see why this move here wouldn't
work
h5 is coming little detail is always
that Knight e5 it's not threatening
anything like night xf3 s still g7 hangs
hello we're not sure what his movies
Brooke h5 looks pretty good this one
okay Queen DT for that is coming back so
I go and get five here right rook e8 a
sudden this show okay let's let's do
this first
just hope that my rook is not taking up
an offside post but don't believe it
yeah that's fortunately no verily to
ignore that
now a queen bee tour that looks normal
the teching g7
it's really not clear what he does to
attend to both rook air-five and Bishop
g7 oh no I don't see move
I don't see one
yep just dropping back
is there something better than Bishop
takes g7 how to believe that any tactic
or anything why that wouldn't work I
don't see it let's take that pawn
and let's check what I'm actually
threatening maybe even Bishop h8 for
Queen g7 mate
yeah maybe Bishop h8 bishop f8 and
Bishop f6 back or so it looks like some
mating attack is just around the corner
okay so is attacking f3 I have a couple
of options if I take it
take it Queen takes okay that's not
maybe not entirely convincing at least I
don't I don't see a checkmate happening
I've looked g32 protected good evil is
probably not a good idea that looks
wrong is there something else that I can
try to do some active windows with with
threats
doesn't look like it rook g3 is a
possibility just covering I mean very
simple probably also sufficient that's
the lazy man's answer probably but if it
works it works
can he play something like a Bishop f3 I
thought wouldn't work yeah I don't work
I can't even take with the rook what is
do I have a very very substantial threat
Bishop age 80 students Bishop f8 to
continue
one additional point of route g3 is of
course that sometimes you can go to h3
and just crashing through on asking
position yeah it's a really long game
we're really taking are we using that
time controller to the fullest
it's possible that she can just go rogue
age three and cheek okay that's a slower
move Bishop age eight is going Bishop f8
and then Bishop f6 I guess or if I go
Bishop to h6 yes f6 as an additional
idea what is Bishop e6 actually doing is
it threatening anything I don't see it I
don't really see a problem so I'm going
for that for Queen g7 mate and Bishop f8
I go Bishop f6 after which is rook hangs
and I'm ready to continue from there or
is there anything better let's think
about it briefly where Bishop f6 looks
good though that's that's a super square
on f6 and I'm winning a tempo on that
roof I had a bishop on e6 was too
discreet just covering discovering h3 if
that is the point
anyway he moves the rook and then what
how I'm I'm shocked meeting him am i
checkmating him in the first place I
definitely need the Queen for that
cannot do it with with rooks alone even
though rook takes g6 is is something to
keep in mind
Oh interesting not minding that group
trade
okay of course I can take it just I'm
not entirely convinced
but I don't really want to activate his
Queen there to d5 I don't like it don't
like that idea
that is Queen would become more active
yeah maybe not much that I can do about
it really
okay let's take it
I guess you will check with the Queen
activating it a little bit but from
there what do I do
24 and it's got Queen a to stop causing
some trouble how do I win this I don't
see it yet
ace queen can sometimes invade if I go
like 25 or so it like windy too and this
is really not what I like to see but
I've looked rate somehow my King has
gotten a little bit more vulnerable
25 or something
I'm never done sure I don't like this
development very much but okay it's
which this should be very good for white
but it looks a little bit more tricky
tricky yeah maybe I can really just push
h4 h5 okay a queen retreats that's good
news in any case it's h4 h5 good that
looks good actually
why not let's do that I was more afraid
of him keeping the Queen on the D file
yeah maybe I'm worrying a bit too much
and everything is just totally winning
it's possible really is possible
so what what is it that he has left
Bishop g5 we should be fire maybe just
rope g3 back okay this one
you're taking a three it's not a big
deal as I have threatened h5e anyway I
just wonder I have to move the rook in
the first place something like h5 Bishop
g5 Bishop takes g5 this is probably just
winning it's got queen g5 now let's not
let's not be fancy simple stuff is
better so rook G to Bishop takes c3 h5
now that's that's the line what - g3 is
that maybe better just to g3 covers f3
covers h3 and it looks better even
that's the level h5 of course that
threat
yes that's precise I believe probably
not important but no even Bishop d5 it's
not threatening a check or anything I
mean a meeting for check NH 5 is hitting
next month
maybe King evades h5 move the knight but
that's going to be pretty sad if you
have to do that okay that that's it's
protecting sorry
protecting age five so what am I doing
here I can go Queen d4 just quite played
played with simple means
hmm so wonder queen D for Queen age who
was something I don't have made funny
sorry
Queen 24 Queenie to check bishop f8s no
maid Bishop e7 though by a good yes yes
here's a check
I Bishop e7 friends made direct made
okay Queenie for Queen a true Queen D a
check bishop f8 Bishop e7 he's got one
check
just one second Queen e2 queen of admit
okay
Queen a to check on d8 Bishop f8 Bishop
e7 funny pinning situation and he has
one check and Queen e2 is made out of it
so it's not working I have to be a bit
circumspect with the clock here okay
he allows the Queen's right I can also
check here and check on before time
warning but might might be good right
okay let's let's do that end game let's
do the end game in exchange in a pawn so
the good thing about this kind of
endgame is that well the ten second
increment it's really really really
helpful him so we form limiting night
and Bishop yeah
just one or two good technical moves
we'll make sure that it's a relatively
easy business if he plays Bishop f4 I go
rook chief or double attacking and here
I have Bishop g5 I believe if he trades
it it will be very simple after the
bishop trade route comes to c5 and just
that just very simple technique his
Knight is also totally dominated by the
pawns and Bishop g7 I take on e7 winning
a piece so he has to trade now
Joe yeah he really can only trade no
other move and over here to grab the C
pawn
yeah probably don't even meet the King
for that
black resigned yeah there was an
interesting game the first real game in
that 2510 pool so let's have a recap we
also that game took so long and it's
really late so I'm not going to do a
super deep analysis here but I still
want to check check some ideas and so
this happened I think I keep making a
mistake yeah III is also it's the
resistor move here I think this is I
think this is a bit more precise
actually anyway we get to the same thing
probably Queen here night back and 92
all normal moves 92 your score 27 yeah I
went there for just to make sure that
this is not taken probably not bad he
went here max e3 yeah this was this
mysterious moment where he took more
than 5 minutes and then when truth the
age that is really mysterious a bit
because he doesn't have any compensation
for opponent it's not clear that he had
to do it I mean what is wrong with
and this for example it's not c4 really
such a problem okay
the engine is giving that move that's a
very very interesting move intending
this this year
that's strong it's that's entirely
pointless that's interesting look what
do you want it's it's not that I didn't
didn't see them maybe if he played but
should be seminar I mean I'm thinking a
bit then I was thinking that this might
be just good attacking here it's a very
very weird engine line if someone plays
against you and he plays this thing like
in a very quick time control game with
that idea you know that something's
wrong interesting
I'm not sure remember whatever would
have played a rookie one is strong
though okay um he went here and while I
do I can't really just take it b6 in the
back salmon fishery to castles castles
here yeah okay
we certainly have more than one move
here to look at g6 sorry g3 is of course
also possible maybe better I mean I
didn't really think about Knight G to
that much felt it felt yeah like it
should work this this and now the engine
just says this witness hmm yeah I mean
maybe this was the was a simple simple
way to do it that's possible with rook
g1 coming and I select this attack let's
maybe easier but okay I liked I like
this idea and he went Bishop d6 and
Queenie for okay well it is it is +3
according to the comp and best
no so that wasn't bad a spent long
enough time on it and now he went here I
played 98 yeah
there was just a pragmatic news just
grab it
the computer finds this which is
stronger yeah one one reason I didn't
really look at that because check that
looked scary but it's not really
shackles I have this yeah this is strong
that's a strong move f6 so it's hard to
find it differently then I can take here
and then check I have this this
regrouping which looks pretty good yeah
that was a good alternative but it does
not matter it's not really much weaker I
think than what I did here King edge one
I wasn't happy with that move in
retrospect I took a long time there and
I failed to see this month I mean I had
that idea briefly but didn't follow up
on it the idea is that after g6 I'm just
winning yeah because he has to play f6
and this sucks under the Queen oh that's
wrong Romero the queen is not helping
Knight doesn't have an escape square
that will win easily so he has to do
something other than g6 and this would
be Queen tubes Queen to h4 and yeah I
don't know can I take even or is that my
after that's a bit tricky this thing
here probably has nothing really
happening but lamb I don't know maybe
that wasn't so bad
Knight back
went back here I mean I would exchange
them and I control the whole board
basically this wasn't a great idea I
guess it probably doesn't hurt but check
it was really hoping hoping for this
which is check which is cute if it
happens but it's not checkmate forced
check as he has to check f3 Bishop here
Queen back back again and a5 yeah
probably
probably that was good activating the
rook and now I overlooked a tactic okay
Ruchi six was winning immediately I
thought about it but I couldn't really I
couldn't really find something here in
my thoughts yeah this is this is
essential made so not working but rook
a7 this win yeah because if the Queen
goes back and then Bishop c4 okay
so this this this would have been much
stronger than if he does that have six
chance shake here yeah of course and now
again he cannot go here do to do to
checkmate made okay that would have been
queued up g6 no I thought about it but I
didn't really get all the points and I
like this idea of bringing in the rook
over it's it's not that not the best
move according to the engine but yeah
it's not bad I think it keeps the
material it is aggressive in some way
it's always like +2 yeah the engine
doesn't approve that wants to go to d3
and still gives me two points
an advantage yeah I can really just take
it here's a simple move and Bishop h6
okay is a bit stronger but I don't think
that this is a mistake
is it takes takes engine gives efore
whoo yeah baby nothing wrong with that
move I think yeah I was thinking that
maybe staying on the D file was a bit
stronger but ultimately I can I can
improve slowly like this for example to
rook g1 back h4 step by step ok went
here H form back that just went back I
think that this was interesting but I've
also been irritated by this I cannot
move the bishop
that's his hangs but Queen f6 will win
so then h5 was good but okay it's not
bad to retreat the rook age five was a
threat this oops and Queen DeForest is
the pragmatic choice the line that had
to be calculated was not this but Queen
a two after which check check bishop f8
Bishop e7 will win for Queen takes f8
mate no he only has chat one pretty
pointless check okay King back on and
now I just I just went for the trade no
yeah that that's technically speaking
the easiest Bishop yourself check will
blunder piece so we took took yeah I
know I get the c7 pawn so it seems that
I overlooked one or two things that
couldn't could have won a bit quicker
but it seems that I always kept
have good control over over the game
okay guys thanks for watching this